[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are going to be watching and
listening to our respective commencement
speeches that we just gave at North
Carolina State University our alma mater
we each gave the commencement speech for
our respective
engineering department me the Civil
which actually they're calling it civil
construction and environmental
engineering ccee now and you the
industrial engineering department which
is now called industrial systems
engineering oh they've added things
they're changing stuff they're expanding
and thanks to us I'm sure we purposely
we've been very excited about this it's
been um you know I don't know almost a
week since we uh we got back but we've
been very purposefully
we knew nothing about this going in
about the other guy's address because we
were waiting until this moment and I
can't tell you how many times during our
time in Raleigh yeah they were like
it became this thing amongst everybody
who was there and they knew oh well
can't see links as a speech and
link can't see Rhett's speech and
they're well they would talk about it on
a podcast we're not at the same time
well I could have we could have attended
each other's we decided not to to
preserve this moment and also because
um
I just thought it would be better if you
weren't there I don't know how you felt
about me being there for you but I
didn't want to be a distraction to the
crowd and I didn't want to be a
distraction to you but I felt like you
might I don't know I just didn't
I didn't want you to be there I I now
get into reasons why okay but
interesting I am very excited about this
because
this entire thing is such an interesting
experiment that I realized on the flight
back you know I leaned over and I was
like this is it's kind of a wild
preposition here that or proposition I
think is the right version
um we were both given the same very
unique assignment to give a
speech
in front of a very specific group of
people that were very similar and in
terms of like an experiment with like a
control group you know a group of
graduating Engineers that went through
school at the same time the only
difference is one civil and the other is
industrial engineering but we're given
the exact same assignment yeah
what do we do with that completely
independently
you know because we didn't
we didn't really trade notes and talk
about what our approaches were we didn't
just not trade notes we didn't speak at
all about these
all the only thing the only inkling that
I have
is I saw you taking like making notes on
the plane and I like saw one word
I saw one word which I'm not going to
tell you what that word was because
when I saw that one word
I was like
hold on I think he may we may have
approached this in a similar way that
was the only thing I saw one word and I
was like wow that word is in mine and
then the only there's no way we
approached it oh no no no no no but
there's no way no no approaching it I
know you didn't approach it in a similar
way I'm saying that I'm saying
thematically I wondered are we are we
talking about things similar themes and
then the other thing was when um
I arrived later to the mckimmon center
which is where they do I mean boy it is
like a graduation Factory in there I
mean it was just this giant Convention
Center which I don't I guess we had been
in like one time before for
graduation
um I just I can't remember where that
graduation was but the only thing I ever
saw in the mckimmon center was it like
does God exist debate oh yeah we uh was
that a William Lane Craig thing yeah I
believe so but then we uh
I walked by while you were when you were
up there I walked down the hall and I
looked in and like you were I just saw
you standing over the podium with your
hands on the podium kind of like with a
twinkle in your eye and I couldn't hear
anything you said but I was like there
he is he's doing it so I'll find out
later and here we are a week after said
event and we're I'm finally gonna get to
see what you did I don't think I would
ever watch mine back if it wasn't for
this so I'm glad we're doing this
because you know there's just never a
time to sit down and
watch a speech and like know that I'll
be like
I don't know why I might not feel good
about it I might be super critical of it
you know
um it when it's done live it's it's made
for that room and the people who were
watching when it was live streamed but
now to watch it back it's a different
vibe
and it's not one that I wanted to sign
up for except in this context right I
think there's a maybe there's a lot to
learn after we watch both of these
things so
who's are we going to watch first how
are we going to do this
well I know mine's shorter than yours I
was I also know how long yours was
because I Jenna told yeah you that Mom
was over 20 minutes yeah and she told me
that yours was like 16 minutes yeah and
we were there was supposed to be 10
minutes but it was interesting
I doubled up a question I did not
understand the assignment I asked you I
was like so how about how long because
they told us about 10 minutes is what
they said and so I asked you how long
yours was and you said I knew if I
planned for 10 minutes I'm gonna go 15.
whatever right that's just what happens
yeah but when you said 10 minutes I was
like okay so he's gonna go he's gonna go
25. that's what I that's what I thought
that's what I thought in my heart of
hearts but you went 22 20 22.
uh like a sitcom uh and maybe you can
compare it to a sitcom in other ways
once you watch it let's let's do mine
second I just feel like I got I just
feel like it's um
it's longer and it's uh so if people get
if mine's too long and then they can't
if they just can't stay through mine
then I don't want them to miss yours
well and let's establish something let's
establish something if they can't hang
on we'll give you our perspective on
this this is not a competition okay even
though you people cannot help but make
everything a competition and in
comparison it's human nature we get it
but that is not what we are doing today
we're not seeing who did a better job it
wasn't about that it's about an
exploration of how I mean we may think
it but we explore things
in our own way and we do things
differently we approach these things
like you said right similar assignment
in particular ways and most of the time
in life even if we're doing something
individually if it involves a large
enough audience there is some
consultation in the way that you would
consult your best friend but also in the
way that you would consult your business
partner and your sort of public figure
partner
um so this is kind of an unusual thing
that we have no idea and there's no
advising that went into it anyway and I
didn't
um the only
and really this was a a function of time
um as with all things in our lives this
snuck up on us and so I was
uh one week before the commencement I
had not written anything
just which is a little unusual for me
but actually pretty typical of of our
lives right now
but that weekend before is when I kind
of created my outline and then over the
next couple of days I would
um
kind of reconfigure my outline and I and
I made a decision unlike when we did uh
our commencement speech back in for high
school for our high school 12 10 years
however long ago that was which we did
as a Duo and we and one of the reasons
we did we did this because it was a Duo
but also it was a little bit more
typical of all the commencement speeches
that we watched in preparation was
people basically go according to a
script
and so I made the decision
to not go according to a script go
according to an outline and kind of know
what I was gonna say but specific
phrasing
there was no notes but besides outline
an outline that I would return to to
make sure that I'm hitting the points I
wanted
so that was my Approach going in was I'm
not going to do a scripted thing the
weekend before this is the commencement
address was on a Friday so the weekend
before I was on like a a weekend away
with Christy
we were having a romantic getaway
and by the time Sunday rolled around I
actually wasn't coming back until
Tuesday so I had Monday Monday was when
we were coming back Sunday
is when it hit me like all the nerves
associated with this thing and I became
very distracted to the point where I
apologized we were there with like a
couple other friends and I was like
listen guys I'm I didn't want to bring
up my work but like I just want to let
you know that
today I've been hit like with a ton of
bricks of preoccupation with the fact
that I'm giving this commencement
address and
um
I don't know what I'm gonna say yet the
only thing that I did know the only work
that I had done was like mental work I
had done visualization work you know
like actually in the crowd naked like
it's like picturing the free throws
going through the basket kind of a thing
picture like knowing how I wanted to
come across
and kind of boiling that down to
well I wanna
I Wanna Be Me
like I wanna
I wanna I wanna have some fun with it I
want to be helpful to the graduates I
want to connect
and I want to be I want to seem
comfortable up there and I want I don't
want to I don't I don't want any notes
don't want any notes I'm going to go up
anybody to give you notes I don't want
to have anything I don't want to have
anything written down this is what I
thought I want to go up there and just
know what I want to say and I just want
to say it and I never want to look down
at notes I want to make eye contact with
the graduates I want to connect with
them and I want it to be kind of down to
earth like a fireside chat I want if it
feels like a podcast a little bit
I think I would be fine with airing on
that side of it and then as I started
planning what I was going to say
I actually have my my notebook I was
like I was writing it I was writing it
in notes and then the night before
um you are out to dinner with your dad
for his birthday because it just
happened you know it was perfect
um and then me in general now got
something to eat and then afterward I
was like
I was kind of telling Jenna what I was
what I just told you that I was thinking
like I don't I haven't written anything
now I just have my phone and I feel like
I'm gonna have to look at my notes so
now I'm gonna be looking at a phone yeah
and it's going to seem like I'm up there
giving a speech but also like checking
my texts that's not a good look so I
need note cards so no cards we're like
walking game show hosts that's what I
thought so I'm like let's go to a
drugstore and buy some note cards and
I'm gonna go back to my room
and write note cards this is like the
night of in my hotel room and so we go
to the top there's a Target on
Hillsborough Street there's a Target
Hillsborough Street boy what what a
comeback now go in there I'm looking at
the note cards and then I look over and
I was like you know what note cards
you're like you're juggling things you
get them out of order what am I gonna do
and I'm like this is what I'm gonna do a
spiral bound college rule notebook
because I tomorrow morning you know what
I'm gonna do I'm a rule college with my
Commencement Address so so very quickly
you went from I'm gonna have no notes so
I'm going to have a notebook oh and I'm
gonna fill it full this is an
interesting Evolution I mean look at
this don't read the words but just one
page two page three page I think that's
about uh we're well about we're well
above 10 minutes at this point there's
no fifth page but like I'm like I'm not
gonna get this out of order because it's
spiral bound and I'm gonna go and look
I've sir I've and then I I've like
circled or squared something I've double
underlined some things so I'm going to
make eye contact with the graduates as
much as possible
but if I need to look down I can just
look at my squares
and I'm just because you know what I was
like I'm not gonna compare myself to
Rhett I mean I feel like you're better
at this type of thing than me I mean
it just like being able to execute
getting up there and giving a speech
it's just you're
if it fits your Vibe and you have more
experience doing things that are if not
that closer to it like emceeing events
and like having
a logical exposition of points that you
want to take people through this is not
the world that my brain lives in right
um and I was like you know what
one of my values is is just doing my
thing
so there's not it's not productive for
me to try to do what I thought would be
your thing
um so that was part of my mindset and I
gotta say I was
um
I was pretty I was freaking out that
weekend before you know and then once I
started
figuring out what I exactly wanted to
say
I started to feel better I started to
get excited about the content of what I
wanted to say and then I knew well I'm
not gonna there's other things I knew
that I don't want to give away my
Approach but
uh I had some some some things that I
was going to do that I thought would
help me
in my Approach and I can point some of
that stuff out
um so then I started to feel better I
would say that like
um by the night before when I was
writing in this notebook I was actually
feeling pretty decent
you know I wasn't freaking out anymore
it was for me I've I'm I'm not afraid of
public speaking I'm afraid of trying to
public speak and making a complete fool
out of myself because it it implodes
because I just don't have it together
or I'd you know something weird happens
you know how things happen to me it's
like anything could happen
and that's true that's true so but once
I and not knowing like knowing I need to
prepare but not being prepared yet oh I
hate that feeling like that's why I've
never been a procrastinator because it
would drive me nuts so beforehand I felt
pretty good
um and then that morning I was feeling
I was feeling
on a scale of one to ten
ten being like
this I've just got this in the bag maybe
I felt like a good solid seven
and I was I you know for a few days
there I was living on like a two wasn't
it wasn't good
how did how did you feel I mean what's
the emotional Arc of your preparation if
you put it in like the scale of one to
ten
well there's a I mean there's a nagging
uh until you know what you're gonna say
right there's a nagging thing underneath
your conscious experience that manifests
itself as anxiety that you keep finding
yeah over the weeks leading up to it and
I'm like and I just tell myself I'm like
this is not a big deal like this is not
a big deal because
whatever I bring to this group is going
to be
um
more than what they're expecting at
their civil engineering graduation let's
just be honest with about it right
because this isn't like the whole school
where they like bring that's where they
bring in some like celebrity from the
the alumni or whatever for the civil
engineering yeah like for the Department
General the departmental formulation
that's what they did this year the
departmental graduation sometimes I
don't even know if it has a guest
speaker sometimes
but so I was kind of minimizing it in my
own in my mind thinking that as a
technique I'm gonna be doing something
that's unexpected
um just by being there to to try to give
a talk that is yes I mean my focus was
to be connecting but obviously it's like
I'm coming in there my reputation being
that I am an entertainer right and so
well this better be funny it better be
entertaining right so that's kind of was
in my mind he better not implode was
what I had to do but the way that we
work uh which I guess is pretty typical
of like you know creators but it's not
typical of
um like if you were a stand-up comedian
or an actor a traditional person
traditional Talent
you would get someone to write your you
would probably get somebody to write it
for you or to write it with you that's
what they all do and every time they
show up to do something but like I we
didn't consult with anybody I went
through the outline with Jesse one time
just so that somebody could hear what I
was gonna say but we operate kind of in
a little bit of a bubble and so I think
that as the day was approaching there
was a little bit there was anxiety of
like
this makes sense in my mind but like I
haven't run any of these jokes by
anybody and like I was gonna go pretty
joke not I mean
not joke joke but like there's a number
of things that I'm going to say that I
am intending to be funny and I'm also
because I'm going okay don't call them
jokes but because I'm going according to
an outline I also know
I'm going to be presented with
opportunities for new jokes to come to
life in the moment because I'm not going
according to a script
and when you throw out
two jokes a minute in 16 minutes or
whatever are they all going to land and
what happens if they don't land I also
thinking like I haven't done this in a
very long time I had okay maybe over the
course of our life I've got experience
kind of getting up in front of people
but like
not recently by myself me and you get up
and do things together but like
this is this I was surprised with how as
it got closer I was like I don't know if
I'm ready for prime time you know that
you started Rusty so I was a little
rusty thinking I was the anxiety was
increasing and also the like the
rationalization process of minimizing
if it was a big deal or not to try to
cope
that was what was happening but I didn't
imagine blaming into denial but as it
was getting closer and closer I was like
I feel good about this
I don't feel great
because I don't think your posture
doesn't say I don't agree I don't think
I have a right to feel great about this
because this is the first time I've done
this ever really
and last thing I'll say because I want
to get to them
is
I was like how many times have the two
of us found ourselves in situations
where we are bringing something
that no one is asking for we do it all
the time like we have a lifetime that's
great of bringing things usually so like
to have lowered expect to surprise
people no it's not always great it's not
yeah that's what I said because usually
but not always if you're a stand-up
comedian are you hedging now no no no no
no no no no because because the last
thing I'll say before we watch mine is
what you said to me you said you said
one thing to me
but where my mind was and it well if
you're a stand-up comedian and you show
up at a comedy club
you are walking into an environment
where the people are there to laugh now
that doesn't mean you won't bomb and
that doesn't mean I've never done
stand-up comedy I don't want to
I'm sure it's very very difficult
but the number of times that we've shown
up in a space where no one was expecting
for anyone to try to make them laugh at
all and then there's an adjustment
period where they're like oh this guy's
trying to be funny well maybe I should
try to start trying to think that like a
college church service yeah we are a
rehearsal dinner yeah or yeah things of
that nature but weird a funeral weird
professional situation I'm working a
funeral in my day so I was thinking that
a lot more than you actually and then on
the day of
um
you went first which I was a bit envious
of the fact that you got to go at like
11 A.M and I got to go at 1 30. so I had
to sit there I had to eat lunch I had to
you see you come back in
yeah the one thing that you told me was
is essential I don't want to give the
exact words because that was what you
said about yours and we're gonna watch
your second but you basically encouraged
me to temper my expectations about the
responsiveness of the crowd which was
consistent with what I was thinking
which is these are engineers and their
family
going to an engineering graduation
they're all there thinking about this
transition in their lives in the life of
the person they're there to support but
they're not serious it's kind of serious
they're wearing robes everyone's robed
and hatted and it's a serious atmosphere
and then bringing something that will
have serious points but is not serious
in tone throughout
I was like I don't know how this is
going to go and when you said that it
was like okay all right I will be
prepared for a number of these things to
not land and they won't be responsive
but I'm going to stay the course
regardless gotta stay the course yep
you're welcome
all right let's give a plug for our my
hair song before we get into this the um
you know every every year we release a
vinyl on the mythical Society this year
it's a remake of the my hair goes song
the world is right again because I'm
singing my hair goes up we switched
parts
you know and if you want this you need
what what what do they need to sign up
by uh quarterly or annual third degree
mythical Society membership by June 30th
and this is your last window this is
your last window of time to be able to
get this right you want to maintain that
collection or start that collection it's
a good looking album
um
mythical society.com
hibiscus is brought to you by betterhelp
uh most weeks I
you know my time is filled with this job
that we have here this good old job uh
in my time at home as a husband as a
father yes and you can realize that most
of the week has passed
and I haven't taken any time
for me
and I can't be the best me
for everyone else in my life when that
is the case I feel that it's easy to get
caught up in doing things for others
especially as bosses husbands and
fathers like we are which can lead to
things like burnout and stress and
therapy can give you the tools to have
more balance in your life so you can
support yourself and support others at
the same time I believe in my therapy as
me time
um
it even when I don't know that I have
things to talk about
I end up having stuff to talk about
things to process to understand myself
better and to to to to put myself to to
enter back into the the game you know
it's like take a little me time in the
dug out and get back in the game you
know so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge find
more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash ear earbiscus is
supported by chime good money habits
start with your very first paycheck
especially if you just scored your first
job it's a great opportunity to jump
start a healthy Financial Journey when
you sign up for chime and Link a
qualifying direct deposit you get access
to benefits like getting paid up to two
days early and fee free overdraft up to
200 and with chime there are no monthly
fees no minimum balance and no deposit
required to become a member so sign up
for a chime checking account today to
link your paycheck it only takes two
minutes and doesn't affect your credit
score get started at chime.com ear
that's chime.com ear chime is a
financial technology company not a bank
banking services and debit card provided
by The Bancorp Bank in a or stride Bank
in a members FDIC Early Access to direct
deposit funds depends on payer spot me
eligibility requirements and overdraft
limit Supply See chime.com Spot me
all right I'm so
they recorded I'm almost as nervous each
of our as I was before I actually did it
I feel a little bit nervous
okay here it is so we got yours up here
and um we're gonna try not to talk over
it so we will be pausing it well I've
already started playing it we will be
pausing it so that we can talk so that
you can hear it
and then hear us talk about it
separately
okay so we'll start with um
and this is Jackie Jackie the head of
the department who is uh introducing me
we have one more um
speaker for today and I think the bar is
set really high by these two
oh you already had two speakers the
valedictorian
speaker
Rhett grew up in Harnett County and
graduated from this department magna [__]
laude with a degree in civil engineering
in 2000. nice started down the path of
an engineer working for black and Beach
and then later on I felt called to join
his best friend mom childhood who also
is a graduate of this college to enter a
brand new
industry that was just developing at the
time which was internet entertainment
okay is she stealing your thunder a
little bit so he and his friend
um link Neil I didn't expect
and they started a YouTube video series
called Good Mythical Morning okay that
my youngest son was a big fan of I have
to say was my credibility with with my
kids she said it was I'm just I'm used
to that I told them who I was getting to
meet today
um but that show has had eight billion
views billion that's true imagine that
eight billion views and it doesn't sound
true 15.1 million current subscribers is
that true I think so that is not the
only thing he's done with his
engineering degree
um he and Link also run a mediocre I
like how I'm being mentioned multiple
times business shows for other people as
well just to set your expectations don't
think it said this morning but they've
got about 150 employees working for
their company so maybe correct me if I'm
wrong right but they also if that
weren't enough the best-selling authors
oh wow she's laying it on thick that
have made the New York Times bestsellers
list uh the first one Rhett and Link's
book of mythicality a field guide to
curiosity creativity you didn't get an
intro like this
uh Julie gave me the intro I wanted I'll
say that classes and professors the
expectations are going up and up and up
the more that you know Jackie's talking
about the lost causes of bleep Creek is
a fiction book that reached number 13. I
like how we're going to get to watch
this so welcome home and we're sorry for
you for sharing your your thoughts and
wisdom with the class of 2023. here we
go clap clap clap golf collapse golf
clubs how many people are in the
audience do you think
uh over 500.
there he is you wearing jeans
no
man he's probably built for podiums
tall joke
I'm surprised that made it past your
fact Checker we made all that up
okay so see that was so you've taken the
mic off I'm playing joke so so you had a
tall joke which was planned
well from your seat I was watching
people at the podium I was like I'm
gonna be real big for that I gotta have
something you gotta have a tall joke
um and then you're gonna have a bio joke
okay and you're grabbing the mic so
power move right at the top so you asked
if I was wearing jeans I will this is
the only thing I'm going to talk about
this is the only thing I'm going to say
about the way I look because you're Mr
average size mister mister let's talk
about the speech man no I know you look
great no I'm self-conscious about what I
wore because I've outgrown all of the
suits that I have here so the literally
the day before we went I had to go
to Pasadena and just walk around until
I've found some place that had something
big enough for me and I found the uh the
Banana Republic and the only jacket they
had in the entire store that would fit
me was a white linen
jacket in those pants you could go
straight to Key West and so I was like
and Jesse saw it she was like I think I
would probably go with something a
little more structured but uh that was
all I had so just you know
I was feeling a little bit I was like
I'm wearing a linen jacket I don't feel
like this is appropriate for graduation
but that was just where my that was
where my mind was
um and the only other thing I'll say
about my look is that I have two choices
about how I'm gonna wear my hair to some
kind of event like this it's either down
or up and I was like if it's down I'm
gonna be touching my hair to get it out
of the way which I hate watching people
touch their hair to get out of the way
and I do it all the time and I hate the
fact that I have to do it so now my only
recourses of man bun which is
immediately something I don't want to
have in front of this group
um so I kind of I was going up with a
low level of confidence let me just say
that this is the first time I've
addressed a crowd of mixed company with
this haircut and it's and and it's it
took some adjusting Mixed Company yeah
play
I don't really feel qualified uh to be
here I haven't done a lot of engineering
over the past 20 years
I have eaten a lot of weird stuff with
my best friend on the internet
apparently that's good enough thank you
thanks for having me
um thanks for mentioning you may have
noticed something lately as you are in
the midst of this transition from
whatever you're doing now to whatever
you're about to do a lot of people are
doing some pretty impressive things from
what I just heard
but you've probably noticed that the
older people in your life
are giving you lots of unsolicited
advice
we cannot help it
it is built into our DNA
we we see somebody going through
something that is a lot like something
that we went through in the past and we
cannot resist to force feed you our
nuggets of wisdom
we got lots of nuggets of wisdom and we
love it when you're trapped in a room
and we have a microphone and a podium
it doesn't get any better than this for
us
now the laughter is muffled because
let's just say they're not miked the
crowd is not the crowd is not miked
so they were laughing here you can hear
them I didn't hear him laugh earlier but
I did hear him laugh right there but you
see also look at yeah so this is Anna
here the valedictorian okay uh and she
she'll laugh at the smart and then
there's another very smart all these the
ones on the stage and this will come in
uh with a joke later don't spoil it the
smartest kids
or at least the ones who applied
themselves the most and got the best
grades are on the stage whereas all the
rest of the ones are in the crowd so I'm
looking at both the
the students who just finished undergrad
plus the ones that finished their
master's degree plus the ones that
finish their PHD because they can bind
everybody and then all their families on
the other side so I'm looking over here
to the left because that's where all the
students are yeah for me too
and I am including myself in older
people I'm 45 guys oh yeah I've got this
weird haircut what's wrong with it
what's the well in the back of his hair
what's he doing with that oh no you're
making fun of there it's a man sense
yeah
rat okay
um I have a secret though from all us
older people and that is
we don't have any idea what we're doing
we are making it up as we go
the only thing that we've gotten better
at is appearing like we've got it
together okay I like this do not trust
us oh
don't trust old people
you see that's a secret that we are not
willing to share with each other or you
on a regular basis and it gives you
permission to not listen to anything I'm
going to say okay
but I would like you to act like you are
listening because that would help me
with my performance and confidence oh
yes
I would like you to close your eyes
oh you just said to look at you can be a
little awkward I hate it when people who
are speaking to groups ask the group to
close their eyes but I'm doing it her
eyes aren't closed yet close your eyes
and I'm going to ask you a series of
questions uh I'm not going to come out
there it makes me feel awkward when
people do this it makes me feel
vulnerable because I feel like maybe the
speaker is going to come out and pop me
in the face
I'm not going to come out and punch
anybody in the face why would you even
think that why would you even ask that
I'm not going to do that
I'm going to ask you to do a little
thought experiment with you you asked
him to close their eyes that's bold I
want you to imagine yourself in the
future
10 years in the future the year is 2033.
I'm no longer an engineer but I can
still do math
I'm going to ask you a series of
questions about what your life is going
to be like and I want you to
do your best to
actually make a specific decision a
prediction as to how things are going to
be and I want you to be bold I want you
to
you know pick the thing that you want to
happen the ideal answer okay
keep it realistic now I mean let's be
grounded you're not going to be one of
the first or the first ever civil
engineer to win a Nobel Prize no one's
ever done it you're probably not going
to do it
so keep it grounded keep it realistic
10 years from now you wake up
your hair strolling the stage I like it
are you in your parents house
no shame no shame in that if you are
you in your own place oh look at you
okay
the cameraman's got his eyes closed
there's someone next to you in bed yes
there are still beds in 2033.
with a hard hat on the stage so uh all
the construction graduates wear hard hat
so he was the only one that made it to
that part but there's like 50 of them in
the so if you're kind of a situation cap
so I just reminded a little bit because
you admit you missed it um you missed
another little joke okay we gotta get
all your jokes but since you did pause
man big move here you're like what what
was the rationale and okay I know the
rationale you're getting them to close
their eyes this is a good this is a good
bit but it also is pertinent
it's getting them in the mind frame of
themselves well this is my whole point
as you will see my whole point was about
but don't give me the I want to get the
point I'm saying this sets the stage for
my whole talk oh yeah I'm I'm assuming
so
I mean I'm assuming they open their eyes
at some point yeah next to you in bed
yes there are still beds in 2033.
who is this in bed with you is it a dog
is it a cat are you one of those people
it's not a snake is it you don't don't
listen don't be one of the people that
has a snake or a reptile in the bed okay
it's weird
it's probably unsafe
is it a person is it a person okay okay
you got a person
is this person someone that you know
right now
is this person someone you would like to
know
they don't look quite as good in the
morning do they
time to go to work okay what's your job
where are you going
are you going to a job that is somehow
related to what you just studied
you go into an office do you have your
own office oh
is this job in a in a field that
you did not study for
you working inside you're working
outside are you having fun
okay you can open your eyes unless
you're sitting I didn't come and punch
you in the face I saw the way you looked
at me
oh now you're going behind a Podium
again okay notes if you'd ask me to do
this particular exercise in the year
2000 when I was sitting where you're
sitting right now
I would have
I would have gotten a lot wrong I would
have gotten one thing right I I was
engaged in my life at the time and we're
still married hold your applause uh she
looks great in the morning I think she
might be watching the live stream she
looks great in the morning
but I would have gotten everything else
wrong including my job because as was
mentioned earlier I got a job in an
industry that did not yet exist if you
would have told me in the year 2000 that
in the year 2010 I would be a YouTuber
I would have been like okay I guess I'm
going to be making personalized tubes
for people okay I mean we got
catheters
oxygen things yeah
people like them different different
colors
it's pretty wild that's not what it is
by the way you'll see
um
and the reason that I was able to get a
job in an industry that didn't yet exist
is because things change so much just
during the time that I was in college
but when I got to NC State I did not
have a computer a cell phone
or an email address I got my first ever
email address when I showed up here
that's true
and when I graduated I had multiple
email addresses
a cell phone a personal computer
stop writing and those changes that were
happening to all of us at the time ended
up creating this opportunity that I
couldn't anticipate and think about how
much more things have changed
for y'all since you started school I
mean we talked I mean we talked about
covid a lot
yeah and you had to be in school during
it but it didn't just make it it didn't
make this specific time just different
for you it's made the world different we
live differently we work differently we
think differently because of that social
some other things have happened like
we're kind of sort of involved in a war
right now where there's a legitimate
possibility that someone might detonate
a nuclear bomb like that kind of
happened oh and by the way apparently
there's aliens now why are you trying to
scare them oh did that happen while you
were in school you got aliens people
started talking about it like they're
having Senate hearings about it and
maybe the most important thing the most
significant thing that you're probably
already tired of people talking about
is the revolution in AI that has been
happening over the time that you've been
in school but you're tired of hearing
people talk about it but
you're the first graduating class that
is being deployed into the next step in
your life in the midst of a world where
there's been an absolute revolution in
this and now it's readily available to
the public and it's already changing the
way people are working the way people
are learning in very significant ways
I often wonder
if I could still do engineering I knew
you're going to talk about it you know
what this you had to tube thing doesn't
work out
and
I uh
I had a little chat with my friend GPT
out of curiosity okay
and I entered a series I was like you
know first of all I was just no offense
guys I was in the easy one I was in
Water Resources this is the easy one
right
um okay that's a joke for just them oh
they loved it right
right I mean you know rain pipes tubes
really
there you go
and I was like What if I had to design a
parking lot right now to park 300 cars
and I needed an adequate drainage system
and an adequate retention Pond could I
do that well yes apparently in 12
minutes oh good one-on-one time with
chat GPT I was able to do that and not
just that I was able to have it generate
python code for me that could uh create
a visual visualization of this uh
parking lot with the locations of the
drains really 12 minutes
now I will say that it repeatedly said
you know you really should be working
with a professional engineer really
ah so the robot overlords believe that
your job is necessary at least for now
but what is the significance
do I think this means that your
education is useless parents know
but do I think there is a significance
to the fact that
this Advanced language model that is
getting better by the second already
knows everything that I've forgotten
about engineering
I think there is some significance to
that
but I'm not going to say well it's
you're not going to have jobs no there's
going to need to be a human element in
all this
but as it relates to that thought
exercise
it has made your future incredibly
unpredictable
and what does that mean for you well
unfortunately you're humans
and we don't like unpredictability in
fact we take a lot of comfort in
orienting our present in order to
increase the probability of some future
desired outcome okay in some ways that's
what school is right
you're doing things now you're making
good decisions some of you better than
others
to orient the present towards a future
desired outcome
and what happens when humans arrive to
the Future when they arrive at that
outcome usually it's one of two things
right
first thing that happens quite often is
you arrive at some point in the future
and you do not get the thing that you
wanted and you are disappointed
you're kind of a downer right and then
sometimes you arrive at that point in
the future and you get the thing that
you wanted and you are
disappointed
it's funny how that works
um and it's so common
it's so common for people to arrive at
points in the future and be disappointed
regardless of whether things go right or
wrong
that we've come up with all kinds of
cliches and advice that you've heard
before that's the good news well the bad
news is
you're going to be disappointed in your
future
thank you good night
had a thing the good news is
we've all been here before
and there's actually a lot of wisdom
that has been dispensed that you already
have you already know you've heard these
things before right give it to us
focus on the journey not the destination
well that sounds good live in the
present not the future or the past I
love that don't spend so much time and
energy thinking about what you want be
grateful for what you have now have an
attitude of gratitude get it on a bumper
sticker t-shirt maybe tank top yes
I like that
that's all great it's all great we all
agree but we have a really difficult
time
believing it and feeling it
you know if when I was sitting where
you're sitting and if you had told me
this I would be like yes I agree with
all this everything you're saying is
right you gotta it's about the journey
not the destination
you got to have an attitude of gratitude
but I would go on over the next 20 years
to continue to attach myself to Future
desired outcomes and to arrive at those
things and let me tell you
this whole tube thing has gone pretty
well
people are really into the tubes I got a
lot to be grateful for but I have still
arrived at these points in my life and
experience mixed in with contentment
this disappointment
so what would I say to myself knowing
that you probably like me you get a
little headrest would agree with these
ideas but might have a difficult time
really making it a part of the way you
navigate life
well I had another chat with my friend
GPT oh I entered everything that I have
said thus far
into the prompt and asked it to give me
a compelling
dramatic
ending for a group of graduates cool so
you cheated
this is what they said
as you stand on the precipice of a new
chapter in your life dear graduate
remember to seek the nourishment of
Happiness within the fertile soil of
personal growth and the present moment
though the Allure of future achievements
May beckon entwining your contentment
too tightly with their attainment can
leave you adrift
it's natural to dream but let your heart
remain rooted in the Here and Now for it
is within this balance that you will
truly flourish as you embark on life's
Grand
Odyssey
Y'all Gonna clap for a computer
oh
okay listen
I was not that impressed with what Chad
GPT had to say I didn't find it all that
compelling and you know why and maybe
you agree y'all go clap is that I knew
that that perspective did not come from
Human Experience it came from Human
mimicry it didn't come from someone that
can experience disappointment it came
from something that has learned how to
talk like someone who can experience
disappointment
and so instead of leaving you with that
I'll leave you with this
you are going to experience
disappointment
at various stages in your life you're
going to get to something
like I said whether it goes right
whether it goes wrong you're going to
get there and you're going to be
disappointed
and when you feel that disappointment
realize that it's a gift
the disappointment is a gift that you
can take
and use it to chip away at your
attachment your very human attachment to
specific desired outcomes
and never stop chipping away at that
attachment you'll probably never
completely sever it
but you got to keep trying and also if
your computer becomes sentient
starts doing weird things take your
disappointment and sever the power cord
okay thank you yes
that was better than chat GPT if it
wasn't that would have that would have
been a bit you thought I would end him
you thought I was just going to end with
a chat GPT ending no but I think they
did because they were like oh should we
clap Y'all Gonna clap for a computer put
that on the tank top
that was
good I think that you know you I I can
see so much of you in it and like I feel
like you gave them yourself which I
think was great and like the fact that
you're sharing that hey you kind of
you got what you wanted yet you still
encountered disappointment I think
that's a sobering reality for for these
graduates so
what did they say afterward
um so afterward we went to a reception
uh with parents and students
and
I mean lots of people came up and were
had lots of kind things to say about it
and I mean I
for me it
it really was this like
what would I have when one girl came up
and she said
she I can't I'm paraphrasing here but
essentially she said something like
you actually said something that
made me think like right it meant
something to me and I'm and I'm gonna
take that with me and that was the only
thing I was actually trying to do yeah
was be like you're in this point in your
life and you the person gives a
commencement speech and it's just it's
in the middle of a blur of events over
the course of a couple of weeks and you
don't remember any of it right I don't I
don't remember mine at all and so I'm
like I'm gonna try to be funny enough so
that they'll perk up and listen and then
is there one thing that is true that I
can communicate that would be haven't
been impactful to me
and so that's how that was the strategy
uh and she and the fact that she said
she essentially confirmed like
I got what you were trying to say and
then a lot of the parents came up and
would be like
what you said was so true I'm so
disappointed so true not in you but in
LA in life
and did people quote the uh
uh like when you talk about the water
like cutting on the water uh oh major
people had people loved that Heyday with
that one people laughed afterwards and
then I have a version of that Jenner
Jenny you said that uh you had a good
view of the faculty at that moment oh
yes yeah the The Faculty uh that you
there was a lot of
laughing and then looking to someone and
pointing that I'm assuming was like a
jab at like possibly that whoever had
followed that water degree right yeah
the faculty got a big kick out of it I
mean the reason I said that is because I
literally switched to it because the
other concentration and the in
Structural Engineering was too difficult
for me
um
the last thing I say we got to get yours
is
I forgot what I was gonna say I had one
other thing oh oh
I at times
felt and I didn't anticipate this but
again I don't do this often at all
but there was a couple of moments and
then I feel it again while watching this
is just like
I seem like a preacher I thought the
same thing for me
oh and I watch a lot of preachers I
I did not well you know when you're when
you were making a point about
um the preacher part for me and I think
I was because I felt it for myself and I
think mine was really obvious yours was
not obvious but I pick up on it you know
it's like we've seen so many preachers
that like you fall into this speaking
course many of the cues that many of the
things that we've learned subconsciously
that we just absorbed over the years yes
is from watching like yeah pastors right
speak and they're always trying to
motivate you and they're always making
an illustration they're always telling a
personal story and so so much of our
training came through that and so it's
hard to avoid but just like holding a
microphone and walking around and like
being a little bit dressed up and like
this looks like a a Church live stream
feed
you know what I mean yeah so I
definitely felt that now I'm doing this
talk at NC State University in Raleigh
North Carolina these kids have probably
been to church quite a bit so maybe it's
more effective but
um I didn't particularly like that but I
also don't know how to not do it I think
my favorite part was the the whole
closed eyes bit you know it's like okay
what why does that make you laugh
because that was actually what was
favorable why did you like it
um because it was
I felt like it was a bit of a risk
you're like you're putting people you
know it's like you can be able to close
their eyes I like to I like the fact
that you implicated that
maybe you were thinking you could punch
somebody in the face yeah it's like oh
I've got them in a weak spot
I love that but then it was like it was
participatory and you kind of guided
them through and like like a an exercise
of visualization I think that that will
stick with a lot a lot of people and
then the fact that then you tied it to I
mean
you'll see in mine but like there's some
uncanny moments there in in the
application of that but I think that
that was I think that was really
powerful and then I think you you
sharing that like hey it's even when
it's not good news
we got him you know this is a sober in
reality that can still be good news of
like uh
hacking away at your attachments to some
something that some something that
you're visualizing that just may not
turn out or even if it does it's not
going to be everything you thought it
would be
so I mean without going full Buddhist he
was very Buddhist I felt like that was
um yeah I felt like that was very
I think that was very helpful and very
memorable our commencement 10 years ago
was pretty Christian I think there was a
Bible verse I went more Buddhist but
without without saying that that's what
I was doing okay
um see I'm glad we did yours first
because now mine's longer and here we go
you know it's like do we should we make
it a part two you can make it your own
part no keep it all deposit and this is
a good place to like take a breather if
you're not ready for a second
commencement address but I mean well
maybe we just don't watch mine it's like
no yes we're gonna watch yours now that
you know like you you have so much
composure
are you saying that you didn't
I don't know I don't know how much
composer you're being too nervous okay
okay yeah yeah let's just let's just
play it let's just play it
you get to see the graduates I see the
full bio of our commencement speaker on
the back I will not read to you the full
bio of Mr link Neil yeah and you can
read it is it okay if I call you link
well I'm going to do it anyway so I
didn't say no
link is a graduate of industrial
engineering from NC State link did Burke
as an engineer at IBM before he went on
to a career in entertainment yes and he
and fellow engineer Rhett McLaughlin
right began a company and are well known
for their social media presence across
YouTube and many other elements
including books that they have written
podcasts that they have Etc
et cetera if I were to ask our graduates
today I've seen one of the episodes or
videos from Rhett and Link I'm pretty
sure that they would all say yes and
those of you who haven't I encourage you
to check it out later it was almost
about as many people in the audience
maybe 500. it may seem interesting to
you that we've invited a little lesson
in the entertainment industry from
YouTube to speak to Engineers today but
I will tell you that I know link is
still an Industrial Engineer down to his
soul
and his career is an example of how
flexible the industrial engineering
degree is
now if you know if you've watched much
of the the work by Rhett and Neo red and
Link you will sometimes see that they
are self-deprecating so he says don't
expect too much and so I'll leave you
with that uh and uh and uh please join
us she gave you the self-deprecating I
told her to say that oh oh I said lower
the bar don't expect too much I said
lower the bar that's what you want
somebody to say yeah
now there's a picture of you up there on
the screen yeah there is
I didn't get that
notebook okay
congratulations
[Music]
man look at you
honestly you don't look nearly as scared
as that thought you should
you know you should be happy
but you should be scared not because of
your future but because I'm giving your
Commencement Address
anything can happen
anything
I don't know what's going to happen
exactly
strong start you see that yeah so
similarities here yeah you're uh not
unexpectedly your mic grab was a little
bit more aggressive than mine yeah I
mean but I mean but uh also I mean same
thought same thought you were like I'm
not gonna get up there and stay behind
the podium yeah uh but you I mean
immediately you you you did the walk
before the talk
you came to the edge of stage before you
even said a word it's I mean I like it I
like it it feels it feels feels powerful
I like your I like your pinstripe suit
you can't really tell that it's
pinstriping on this but thank you for
pointing that it was a good start yeah I
snatched that thing that was just pure
energy
that I I it was just coming out of
everywhere
um
but I do want to give you a gift
I want to give you a gift
of the tale of elkhouse
oh my gosh
Once Upon a Time
in the pandemic
it was a middle-aged man with glasses
green goofy hair
and a successful internet show
who wanted to be a DJ
did I get a chuckle from the camera
person
a DJ
it is short left
he liked
playing music for his friends but then
one day he took a big step he decided to
buy a DJ deck I'm talking about one of
those
boxes with a big circles on it and all
the buttons
do you know what those buttons did of
course not
but he didn't know the one thing that
you all know about a DJ
and that's this you're not really a DJ
until you played a gig in public
say what you want
if you haven't played a gig you ain't no
DJ okay let's pause at this point first
of all there was no cameraman
I looked over at the camera it wasn't
anybody there so who's snorting I don't
know somebody near the camera oh
somebody near the camera
okay so this is unexpected like I did I
would not have I would not have been
able to I would not have been able to
predict that this would start with the
tale of Elkhound snuggle baby
um so it's hard to see their faces
because I'm only seeing the backs of
their heads at this point so at this
point
at this point in your story
what are you getting from them
very little
and that's why when I walk back to the
podium I like I was like he wanted to be
a DJ and then I was I was like I looked
down at my notes and I was on page four
and so I'm like turning my spiral bound
number back and I'm saying four of four
yeah and I'm like he wanted to be
flip the page still not the right page
goodbye to page a DJ
and then I got it how I wanted it and
then I'm like thinking oh this is this
crowd is stiff now I'm actually hearing
some laughter
the onboard mic is actually helping my
cause a little bit yeah I just I'm
hearing responsiveness I just want I was
kind of trying to get in your head at
this point oh why I'm telling this story
no when you're telling the story is it
kind of like like are you like where's
your where's your head at I'm I'm like
okay I've I gotta stick to the game this
is I'm telling this story I decided if I
can get in story mode that will help me
yeah if I because I experienced it and
then I just and I feel like I can tell a
story so like I'm gonna lean on that and
I'm gonna have like my like the key
moments of the story written down like
when I tell a story here it's like I
might write down a key point or two so I
just it made me feel a little more
comfortable but then that was met with
like kind of like some Shock
you know it was just like I don't like
people they didn't know what to do with
it they didn't expect it right so and
I guess I did the thing that I did on
purpose was deciding to tell this story
that would just surprise this is not
what anybody expected yeah okay so and I
thought it I thought it set up what I
wanted to say so I mean you'd be the
judge of that
foreign
he decided to make an announcement
and he said I'm going to play my first
ever DJ Gig at mythica now for those of
you who don't know which I'm sure is the
minority mythicon
is a convention full of supporting fans
of let's just say from this aspiring
DJ's day job
okay
so making that your first gig it kind of
mitigates the risk a little bit right
these are supportive fans
of this guy but still it's over a
thousand people I mean that's that's
that's quite a premier game you know
maybe you should have thought about
starting a little smaller
but it was too late he had made that
announcement
at this point this is no longer just
some fun little hobby this is getting
real bad
yeah real scary
I'm scared
okay I'm Not Gonna Keep pausing it no
you can pause it but but I'm just I'm
putting myself in the shoes of a student
yeah who doesn't know who you are yeah
and it's like I'm processing so many
things and all of a sudden right there's
man up there it did seem like they were
processing a lot and he's saying things
like really scary
right right I I made up my mind I was
like I'm Gonna Be Me yeah and you're
gonna have to reckon with it yeah
mission accomplished
but he knew the most important thing
about being a DJ was picking out a DJ
man every good DJ has a good DJ name he
wanted to pick out something that was
Unforgettable yet kind of hard to
remember
he wanted to pick out one a DJ name that
when you said it out loud you couldn't
keep a straight face
yeah
and he came up with Elkhound snuggle
baby foreign
but let's test it out all right we're
gonna we're gonna wake up a little bit
be a little too serious
I would like to count to three and then
in unison oh
I would like all of us okay
I'm gonna count for three please
cooperate
one two three
he was right he's mine
so we had that figured out and then he
knew he didn't look but every good DJ
has a signature look sometimes they have
a costume some some DJs are doing the
health thing
so ES
that's sometimes call them
decided that he was going to drink a
fake cheats wool fabric over his bare
shoulders and chest
um to look kind of like a viking tunic
and then he had an enormous headpiece
piece made
that emanated from his head region
and it was too huge let me do this
two huge
elk antlers spread it about two feet
above his head
in about five feet across
they look pretty vicious
but also a little bit
so we had to make
he had the signature to look
and then
the night of his set finally arrived see
I'm seeing why it took me 22 minutes
story is pretty detailed I
knocking three times as slow I'm talking
on one third speed that always happens
when you see you speak though when I get
up there I'm speaking way too slow right
yeah it's usually like a if you plan for
10 it's going to be I gotta I gotta
speak faster next time I give this exact
speech right because you'll do this
again all right
um that's that's my main critique of
myself is uh I'm speaking too damn slow
I got I'm losing my energy I'm losing
I'm losing I'm losing my vibe but now
I'm at the gig I'm not I'm not done with
this story
right right right right okay
and kick things off
24 Karat Magic it's called Bruno Mars
pinky fingers to the Moon
you're really getting this person next
to the camera
he sprinkled in some 21 Savage
don't say nothing
now you're connecting with the kids yeah
he seamlessly transitioned from Toto's
Africa into Snoop Dogg's
drugs stirring
[Music]
it was going great
until it wasn't
he pushed the wrong button
he maybe he forgot how the buttons
weren't
maybe he
nobody knows what happened I'm pretty
sure he doesn't know what happened but
it was pretty clear that
he was unable to play his next song
in fact he was unable to play
any song
which as it turns out is pretty
important
or a DJ
at this point he took another big step
and grab the microphone
and he made an announcement
he said
I would play another song
but I can't figure out how so
[Music]
uh I'm just gonna leave now
and he did we
stayed which wasn't easy with them
we never heard from him again you know
actually
uh they'll count snuggle baby
did live to DJ another day even though I
think what happened was most accurately
described
as an implosion
he did Live Another Day how do I know
that
because I was stand before you today
at ltown snuggle base
I said bet you didn't see that coming
not yet right
because you've got a college degree oh
that's good
see it was me
yeah yeah yeah that and it was it was a
little bit
for the for a second there they may have
thought you were talking about like a
historical figure
what do you think you were getting from
the uh the parents I was not I made up
my mind I was like I'm not gonna look at
the parents or the grandparents or the
siblings right uh I'm only going to look
at the graduates I'm that's my best
chance of getting through this uh that's
who I want to connect with and
um yeah I think when I got the Applause
it was like uh I think the rental
applause was his story is over
I'm supposed to applaud now but the joke
was
I'm just getting started no no
what a joke
but the joke was that it was that I knew
that I'd telegraphed that it was me yeah
yeah it was good I I enjoy that joke all
right once you got into the uh and that
was my time by the way
I think that when I have an application
to the story right but at this point is
when you get into the like the specific
musical references and the little like
call outs and stuff like that
you can see
their hats start moving a whole lot more
right because now there's murmurs I
think that there is a there is a sort of
a realization of like
this guy
is telling
this story in this fashion yeah and I
think that there is a uh there's sort of
a realization of like this is going to
be interesting
I told him anything could happen
and so I think that at this point
you're getting people to be like all
right okay
yeah where is this going I do feel like
I was I was winning them over a little
bit but now I got a lace and pipe
is that the right no
I gotta I gotta actually say something
substantial yeah right which is the part
where I was like oh I gotta I need notes
yeah go back to the notes Here We Go
why am I gifting
tail
of an elephant snuggle baby well
isn't it pretty clear
now that you have your investment
engineer in degrees drop everything and
pursue in professional DJing
oh that's your thank you good night yeah
okay we both had that thank you good
night
including the implosion
I will say that honestly
I don't regret setting up
you know every single part of it I don't
regret it
and there's just something deeply
satisfying about identifying a passion
and then going after
even if the path to get there is really
unclear even if the results are anything
but guaranteed
that can be deeply rewarding now I want
to go into bad mode with you guys okay
so today I'm hearing yourself I want I
want to give you some advice that maybe
you can use that will help you out as
you enter the rest of your life and so I
have a general
guiding principle that when I look back
over the course of my career and I'm not
just talking about with each career
um I see a pattern of whenever
there were crucial to jumpsters in my
life when I was making big decisions or
small decisions that I didn't realize
would have Ripple effects throughout my
entire life there's one common principle
that was there and I'm going to share it
with you maybe you know take it or leave
it maybe it could be of help to you
is the reason that Elkhound snuggle baby
does exist
maybe more importantly
uh I would say this principle is the
reason
that good mythical morning
Our Daily Talk Show exists
I would say that without enacting
responsible
red and length as a comedic Duo
I don't think good exists and I
definitely wouldn't be up here
talking to you guys
about my DJ emotions if this principle
wasn't at the lights all right you ready
for it you don't have to write anything
down I'm going to Tweet it out later
so people can pick it up did you do that
no
I don't like to tweet
attention instead of certainty
air on the side of action instead of
certain okay so if you think about
certainty as this idea being 100
confident about something before you go
into it 100 confident this sets up this
idea that can become a trap and when you
find yourself making a weighty decision
or figuring out the direction that you
want to go in life today
this year or next whatever the case may
be
you can be lulled into this
beliefs that
I'm not going to move forward until I
know this is the right choice that the
sign is blinking and saying this way do
this you got this just go for it it's
automatic not a silver room in Dallas
I'm saying err on the side of action
because the concept of being 100
confident can be paralyzed the bigger
the decision that you're making the
harder it is to feel like you're making
the right one and
the unknown can be really scary
scarier than a man wearing a headpiece
of alligators five feet wide you know
what I'm saying delicious
throwback to to a joke nobody liked
if you keep waiting for 100 certainty
um you might be all into a position
where you're not listening to your heart
and following your heart you might be
loaded to a position where you're not
taking any action at all
okay so
if I know means my frugalist decisions
you should use every resource that your
disposal to make the wisest decision
possible but when it comes down to
making these decisions and
uh what
find a piece about it or or
um confirmation about it whatever
whatever words you want to use at a
certain point I want to encourage you
when it comes down to it you can err on
the side of action taking those big
steps instead of certain take a
direction and go
you know I don't like to call them dead
ends I like to call them colder stats
I made that up hey that was good that
was a it was getting kind of dry
well I was getting kind of preachy
well you so I hit him with a cul-de-sac
and you uh so you you we we took the
theme of uncertainty as well but you
took a different you know it's a
different aspect of uncertainty right
and then that's the word that I saw on
your notes
on your phone yeah it was uncertainty I
was like oh I'm talking about
uncertainty yeah what is he talking
about I know and now listen to this
because even though my speech could have
been done a lot earlier or even right
here I'm still not done y'all I'm going
into the third Act
right and this is where it gets a little
uncanny in in terms of some parallels
22 years ago
I was sitting
I remember that feeling
special point
in your life is a few times where
um it inflection point is so palpable
you know do you feel like your life is
you're on the aggressiveness of the rest
of your life
and there's a few times that you're
going to feel this way again and you
know like I said you should be scared
um
I can feel that my life was out there
but I couldn't see it
I couldn't see it knowing what it is now
there's no way I could have seen it
um that doesn't mean the Flames won't
fall into place as Julie mentioned
when I was sitting where you are I
I had some plans I accepted the job
and I am working in their industrial
engineering department just down the
road in RTP
um within a few months I would be
connected and conveyor belts
and
process optimization of computer partner
refurbishment
thank you
uh it was it was pretty sexy
pretty sexy yeah
I like this yep
what'd you say what Rod give me another
one
Optimum
you another one come on
speaker
[Music]
I was in it this is a good this is a
good moment you're really you're tapping
into the this stuff This Is My Water
Resources moment they identify
themselves in this way
and they will for the rest of their
lives I came up with this like this is
the last thing I came up with I was like
Chrissy told me like you got to connect
with your engineering
and so I was like oh I'm gonna do it
with this but I'm gonna make all the
industrial engineering where it's sexy
yeah that's a good call and then so the
main thing that I got was
people coming up to me professors
especially talking about I love the
stochastic one
stochastic fantastic can I use that is
it what is it stochastic
yeah I don't even know what that is I
don't even know if I'm saying it right
stochastic yes we don't do anything
stochastic
yeah it's fantastic
fantastic at one point I didn't know
what it was my apologies
for no longer knowing but yeah I mean
and if my speech wasn't the next day I
would have continued to add things and I
would have had like a 45 minute speech
yep right
I don't regret a minute
my experience
as an industrial
just how my brain works and so yeah I'm
still an industrial engineer
yes
um
I was also already married when I was uh
sitting where you are recently my wife
and I have been I've been married a year
she graduated from Meredith College my
show of hands is anybody here willing to
admit to be in our relationship with
somebody from America
come on now I'm going to be in trouble
man when I was here he's like fishing a
barrel over there
Meredith is an all-girl school did you
say fish in a barrel yeah
[Laughter]
but I didn't say shooting fishing
are the women the fish
is that the analysis yeah I guess so
yeah I mean it's nothing but women over
there yeah well fish in a barrel
yeah
we're just keep going
I love my Christie we've been married a
year
you know I had this job
that's pretty much all I knew when I was
sitting in your seat but if you fast
forward two years from this spot
and
they had a lot of change already that I
couldn't anticipated we already had our
first daughter Lily
I haven't already completely changed my
career path
I had left industrial engineering and I
was working for a non-profit as a
speaker and teacher and trainer a video
maker a comedian I use a term really
loosely
um
so yeah I couldn't imagine that and that
was only two years down the road
you took the non-profit right I I
um we talked about this before but like
right the simplified Story We skip over
the campus Crusade stuff because it's
hard to explain
to right people you know to justify it
what's the simplest way to explain it
that doesn't like start to distract from
what the point I'm actually trying to
make it wasn't it wasn't trying to gloss
over something
um for what it was it was trying to
gloss over for just the sake of pacing
which I did not have a great sense of
anyway
yeah but it's funny I mean I everybody
was with me at this point though once I
started talking sexy everybody's parking
back up yeah yeah you got you realize
you reel them back in yeah I reeled him
back in because I had to you know okay
okay four years down the road from when
I was seated Where You Are
that's how long it would be before the
invention that
defined my career completely and change
the trajectory of my entire life was
even invented
I remember in 2005-ish early 2006. I was
asking the president
well
why do we need a YouTube
when we've got our videos on a website
well the answer was somebody took one of
our videos off videos off of our website
and put it on this thing called YouTube
and it got more videos got reviews in a
day
[Music]
a little bit
I mean I could have used your tube joke
here
yeah but we didn't we didn't straight
notes so no I should have you and if you
if we both had the same joke that would
have been that would have been awesome
next time totally different crowd next
time I mean there was a business model
there there was no career associated
with
um but we
we couldn't see the writing on the wall
but we said that I think somebody's
building a wall maybe one day we can
ride them
you had to build the wall joke yeah
yeah
but he's riding on them but I was
waiting for someone to build his [__]
ride on you you know I'm a graffiti
artist with you man you knew Trump you
knew Trump was coming along
I'm gonna ride on that wall I mean that
was tough to write on though because
just like slats you know that was uh
totally off the cuff
you didn't exist when I was sitting
Where You Are
you are wrap it up son so if you feel
like you have no clue what your future
looks like
oh you're right I mean
don't freak out
none of us did we're all waving this up
look at all look at everybody else we're
all making this up right as we go
so maybe your career doesn't exist yet
either maybe you need to invent your
career
maybe you need to buy your time
um
so that you can say yes to the right
opportunities whenever that comes about
you know it took me a long time to
discover
Tulane
but I'm no longer going to puberty
I don't know why I said that
was that planned no
it took me a long time to discover who I
am but I am no longer going through
puberty wow
I don't know yeah okay well it's true
it's true I don't know I don't know it's
true
yeah I did want to clear I said I'm glad
I could clear that up and you did have a
late puberty I did yeah
uh
in the meantime I would say don't sit on
your hands too long or they may never
wake up
I want to encourage you to follow your
heart I want to encourage you to like I
said air on the side of action instead
of certainty
and I want to lead you yes as any
globally known
accomplished DJ wood
with a song oh
this is from Tom Eddie
you're going to play this no yes
[Music]
what lies in here and I have nowhere
baby the grass is growing yeah it's time
to move along
yeah it's time to move on
it's time to get going
it's time to move on
it's time
oh I wanted to see what she said
she dropped it like it's hot I think wow
um you know what
um
they're not gonna forget that link
yeah you know under my feet baby the
grass is growing it's time to move on
you know it's like air on the side of
action instead of certainty I think you
know Drop it like it's hot I think uh
you set out to be yourself
check I fit and I do feel good about
that I feel like I I went big and I went
for it and I was like I'm not gonna they
rattled me at the beginning and that's
not you know not their fault but when I
watch it back I'm like uh yeah I just
need I need to talk a lot faster but I'm
glad I
said I think it's the first time that I
kind of brought myself to brought myself
to it to something like this
you know
it a speech awesome right right and uh
I think if you were to add I mean for me
the most important thing is like I mean
obviously we're like we're trying to do
it to be entertaining and
um and like you know
because we're entertainers which you
definitely did
But ultimately the most important thing
is
do they walk away with something that
actually
means that they understand and motivates
them in some in some way like that's
what that's what you that's what you're
after when you when you give a give a
talk so I think that my point was
basically like go for it you know it's
like it's not you know it's like your
point was just do it it was like just do
it it was like go for it it was like
Nike's slogan yeah
um which is important and also I think
that
probably
just because of the way people's
personalities map to certain professions
I would think that there's a lot of
perfectionists in the crowd because
industrial Engineers are nationally
drawn to
a perfectionist or naturally drawn to
process definitely and optimization
definitely and people who are drawn to
that also have a tendency to
have a difficult time moving forward if
they don't feel completely confident and
secure so I think that right you kind of
broke them down with the uh
pop peeler references got them on your
side and then gave him something that
was very applicable to them including
very personalized Insider
Jesse stuff sexy stuff so I I had and I
didn't want to tell I wanted to tell a
story that was unexpected but that was
also not a story of success but a story
of failure you know it's like I think
that's more of my sweet spot anyway but
I thought it was like you know
um I don't regret a second of it I think
it was great so
um I think based on those two
performances I'm expecting a call we're
gonna have to go on the circuit to come
back and do the whole whole school PNC
Arena
Coliseum baby yeah
yeah and we're gonna but we'll have to
do it together yeah so we'll have to
figure that out
yeah I think you can mention songs and
then I'll start singing
I I will basically be the DJ hype man
for your composed speech and that would
be a good one-two punch I think that's
what we'll do
do you well we have we have we got at
least a year to plant it uh we don't
know when we'll be asked what we were
honored to to get the invitation and I'm
so I mean it was like it's you know even
if you're tempted to say no I was very
tempted to say no because I I like oh
it's time you got to figure this out
yeah and it's uh you know and it's gonna
make me anxious and it yeah it takes
time too and it's but it's just like I I
was pretty worked up about it you know
so it was um but I'm I was very glad I
did it and you know I just want to give
a shout out to Julie Wanda Karen thank
you all for for having me for being such
um such great hosts and uh being
supportive and believing in me uh yeah
and thank you to Jackie and Amy and the
Civil Department to Jerome the associate
Dean over there at the engineering
school Jerome thank you it was a key
part of this and we we won't talk about
it but we got another tour uh
an even better tour now that it was both
of us yeah of the engineering schools
and it's just I mean it's cool to see
what's going on there it kind of makes
me want to like you know it makes me
want to do a little engineering I'm not
going to I'm just going to use Chad gbt
but like it kind of like when I see the
cool stuff it makes me kind of wanna
uh figure it out and do it again yeah uh
but yeah it was a good weekend it was a
good weekend just just
like being back there it was very
formative for for me I felt like it was
a milestone I feel like there was a
certain level of like oh I I put my you
know I was nervous about it and I was
like
I don't want to do this
and so for me I've I it gave me a
I just felt like I you know it was it
was quite a milestone for both of us
yeah to be able to do that do the high
school do the College commencement
address we have no business doing these
things but at the same time it's um it's
a great privilege and it's just it's
just a cool Milestone and I think it
I've had like momentum on the back side
of it a little more a little more
confidence being a goofball you're gonna
speak somewhere now yeah I think I must
I think I'm gonna start I'm speaking
about my DJing but not dude not DJing
but talking just just talking about it
maybe that's yours what's your what's
your next uh I got to get back on I
gotta get a divorce I gotta get back on
the horse uh get get those antlers back
on but my wreck is
um you know air on the side of action
over certainty
yeah oh that's correct yeah my wreck is
my point
well let us know what you think let us
know what uh how where you moved
um uh how do you are you going to take
this advice and uh dominate the next
stage of your life with it are you going
to start a new career in an industry
that does not yet exist let us know
hashtag ear biscuits or call us 1-888
speak at you next week
okay hey gang I'm listening exactly one
month late to the episode about Link's
ski trip
and I just want to say thank you for
making great content and being amazing
friends who can
talk about each other's
pitfalls
good qualities all the same and it
really makes me think about
and be thankful for the friendships that
I have and feel like I can do that with
and also think about
areas where I need to improve on so
thank you guys love you so much keep
making the cafe
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]